[Musica]
Sono un'appassionata di moda Mi piace
giocare con i colori e con gli
abbinamenti passando dallo stile casual
a quello più ricercato mi piace tanto
davvero tanto ma non è il mio lavoro Io
nella vita faccio tutt'altro ma c'è una
questione della moda che fino a 10 anni
fa non conoscevo è una questione che
riguarda me e che mi crea problemi
probabilmente non solo a me anche a voi
Quanti di voi sanno che la moda ha
problemi con questioni sociali
ambientali e con il rispetto dei diritti
umani pochi probabilmente intanto
scopriamo che l'ambiente è un diritto
umano è stato riconosciuto tra i diritti
umani un anno fa molto recentemente l'8
ottobre del 2021 l'ambiente è stato
riconosciuto tra i diritti umani
fondamentali al pari al diritto alla
libertà alla vita al cibo e all'acqua
sappiamo che il settore
dell'abbigliamento delle calzature è
responsabile del 10% delle missioni di
gas effetto serra A livello mondiale
pensate che emette più gas effetto serra
dei trasporti marittimi e dei voli
internazionali messi insieme senza
contare le missioni di CO2 e
l'inquinamento a cui farò dovuto alla
produzione e alla distribuzione di moda
pensate che per fare un paio di jeans
sono necessari
3.781 litri d'acqua invece per fare una
maglietta ne servono 2.700 litri d'acqua
l'equivalente del fabbisogno di acqua ad
una persona per due anni e mezzo a
questo punto non vi stupirà sapere che
l'industria dell'abbigliamento è tra le
più inquinanti al mondo solo dopo il
settore petrolifero Ma cosa è successo
negli ultimi vent'anni
Intanto sappiamo che l'industria della
moda ha raddoppiato le produzioni in
conseguenza quella che viene definita
fast fashion e sappiamo anche che è
aumentato a livello europeo Il 40% di
acquisto di capi di abbigliamento per
persona in conseguenza una riduzione dei
prezzi e perché i prezzi sono calati
ci ricordiamo perché questo è un fatto
storico che la dichiarazione universale
dei diritti dell'uomo prevede che ogni
essere umano abbia diritto ad adeguati
standard di vita e a vivere nella
dignità e nel benessere ce lo dice la
dichiarazione universale dei diritti
dell'uomo e sono ben 74 anni da questo
da questo importante avvenimento il 10
dicembre del 1948 Eppure ancora oggi nel
2022 non è così per tutti in particolare
le lavoratrici e i lavoratori del
tessile nel mondo vivono in condizioni
di povertà sono ben 35 milioni le
persone che nel mondo producono con le
proprie mani i capi di abbigliamento che
noi Indossiamo e ricevono fra gli
stipendi più bassi del mondo
salari da fame e basse garanzie del
lavoro Sono la normalità per questa
categoria di per lavoratori e pensate
che nel mondo questo settore Quello
dell'abbigliamento è il terzo datore di
lavoro dopo cibo e turismo Ma perché a
me importa tanto di questa cosa sia
nella vita faccio tutt'altro E la moda è
solo una grande passione
torniamo a 10 anni fa era il 24 aprile
del 2013
segnò quel giorno per me uno spartiacque
tra il prima e il dopo tra l'essere
inconsapevole e iniziare a pormi qualche
domanda perché il 24 aprile del 2013 in
Bangladesh il rana palaza un edificio di
otto piani adibito alla lavorazione del
tessile Subì un crollo a causa di un
cedimento strutturale morirono
1135 persone 2.500 rimasero ferite si
trattava soprattutto di donne di giovani
donne operaie che lavoravano per 35
dollari al mese con turni di lavoro
dalle 10 alle 12 ore
e
in quel giorno il loro posto di lavoro
era diventato un cumulo di macerie
il mio impegno professionale coincide
con il mio impegno sociale Oggi sono a
fianco dei bambini a SOS villaggi dei
bambini nel 2013
lavoravo per Action e di
un'organizzazione internazionale
impegnata a rimuovere le cause della
povertà delle esclusioni sociali nel
mondo quel giorno nella mia casella di
posta elettronica arrivo la notizia
dell'accaduto e mi fu subito chiaro che
tra quelle righe c'era di più
dell'incidente che aveva investito il
settore della moda tra quelle righe
c'era la storia delle persone che in
quel posto Ci lavoravano Ecco quel
giorno segnò davvero per me uno
spartiacque e fu come quando si
incontrano il blu del Rio della amazzoni
e il nero marrone del Rio
all'inizio pensai un conto è il mio
impegno sociale il mio lavoro Un conto è
la mia passione per la moda due cose
separate ma non fu stupita nel vedere
che poi così non poteva essere
pensate che il Bangladesh quel
Quel puntino blu che vedete nella mappa
è il secondo paese al mondo per
produzione di tessile e capi di
abbigliamento in Bangladesh ci sono
4.000 fabbriche che danno lavoro a 4
milioni di persone si tratta soprattutto
di donne di giovani donne il 90% è
soprattutto legato a un lavoro di tipo
femminile e pensate che L'Europa è la
più grande destinazione di questi capi
di abbigliamento Ecco perché quello che
accade in quel paese ci riguarda da
vicino e le nostre scelte hanno un
impatto sulla vita di queste persone
iniziai a seguire i report per i
risarcimenti alle famiglie delle vittime
continuava ad informarmi ma la stampa
non ci prestava più attenzione sappiamo
come succede anche quando ci sono dei
disastri a casa nostra quando passa il
tempo ce li dimentichiamo Allora
escogitai un'idea il realizzare una
sfilata di moda di alta moda etica e di
portare l'attenzione al tema lì dove la
moda si decide la sfilata fu un successo
intervenne finì su Vogue rivista di moda
per eccellenza ed espressione
dell'economia Moni driven sul Corriere
della Sera E vi partecipò anche la loro
Sottosegretario al Ministero del Lavoro
e delle politiche sociali Luigi bobba
dopo un po' capiti anche questo non era
sufficiente inizia a entrare in contatto
con i tanti movimenti di opinioni nati
proprio a seguito dell'incidente del
2013 senza mai smettere di documentarmi
in realtà Riflettevo su come le campagne
sul cibo avessero prodotto negli anni a
una riduzione dei dello spreco
alimentare e avessero contrastato la
riduzione dei rifiuti sapete che oggi
grazie anche in parte a queste campagne
l'Italia è tra i paesi del G8 la più
virtuosa in tema di spreco alimentare il
91,6% degli italiani afferma di pensare
sempre spesso allo spreco alimentare
quando fa la spesa cucina o mangia
Eppure gli stessi risultati non sono
riscontrabili nelle campagne Nelle tante
campagne nate a seguito dell'incidente
re dell'anaplaza e purtroppo non solo di
quello
dovremmo tutti interrogarci e porci dei
quesiti in materia etica quando
acquistiamo o regaliamo capi di
abbigliamento per noi o per gli altri
pensate che l'industria della moda
produce 35 milioni di tonnellate di
fibre l'anno il 70% di queste fibre non
viene riutilizzato e pensate che
l'industria della gli abiti che noi
gettiamo sarebbero perfettamente
riutilizzabili una montagna di abiti che
viene gettata che diventa rifiuto e 37
milioni di tonnellate che vengono
sprecate sono equivalenti a 5 piramidi
in Egitto
Ecco sono questi numeri tanti numeri
importanti che vi ho dato che dovrebbero
spingerci a riflettere perché vedete
sono tante le persone che sono state
vittime dell'incidente e che cercano di
condurre una vita normale come questa
donna che vedete mentre la stanno
estraendo dalle macerie con il suo
telefonino in mano ecco le vittime del
rana Plaza di questo incidente portano
ancora sul loro corpo e nella loro vita
le lesioni fisiche E quelle psiche che
non Gli permettono di condurre una vita
normale Sono tanti i bambini rimasti
senza madre ma ciò che dona la speranza
è proprio la consapevolezza che tutti
noi insieme possiamo fare qualcosa di
concreto per evitare di ripetersi di una
tragedia tanto dolorosa
le cose Piano piano stanno cambiando in
Italia si è iniziato a pensare alla
raccolta differenziata dei rifiuti
tessili dal primo gennaio 2022 perché è
diventato obbligatorio ma in realtà poi
ancora non si è tradotto in una
concretezza a livello europeo questo la
raccolta differenziata di questa
tipologia di rifiuti entrerà in vigore
dal Entro il 2025 anche la
consapevolezza della moda c'è e si sta
iniziando a pensare a un ciclo
produttivo che sia sostenibile
dall'inizio ma in realtà siamo proprio
noi consumatori che abbiamo un potere
che spesso non rammentiamo di avere
siamo noi infatti consumatori che non
dovremmo alimentare quelle logiche di
profitto che spesso si Celano dietro i
capi di abbigliamento che noi
acquistiamo e che vanno di pari passo
con lo sfruttamento delle persone e
dell'ambiente come possiamo fare alcuni
esempi concreti aderiamo le campagne per
il rispetto dei Lavoratori molte parti
del mondo
manifestare il loro dissenso e far
valere i loro Stati Uniti è un proclean
un problema queste persone quindi
possiamo aderire le campagne Fest
Revolution abiti puliti acquistiamo di
seconda mano acquistiamo da Brand etici
iniziano a esserci importanti Brand
etici ma soprattutto acquistiamo fibre
naturali il cotone la lana e la seta
sono perfettamente riutilizzabili
rinnoviamo gli abiti diamo una nuova
vita gli abiti che abbiamo nell'armadio
ci sembrirà di indossare un capo nuovo
diverso e infine promettiamo di non
acquistare per 6 mesi o un anno un capo
di abbigliamento davvero in conclusione
guardiamo agli influencer con spirito
critico perché spesso sponsorizzano a
pagamento di brand di moda per indurci
l'acquisto di abbigliamento Ecco in
questo senso non dovremmo mai smettere
di interrogarci per capire qual è il
costo reale che si cela dietro il capo
di abbigliamento e soprattutto
riconoscere se e quali diritti siano
stati calpestati
Grazie
[Applauso]